Atlantis the lost Empire this was
Disney's attempt to try and be a little
bit more adult in that they're trying to
make an action film where people die and
big explosions happen and all that cool
stuff to try get back with a hip
audience again and boy did it backfire
not only did the film do incredibly
poorly at the box office but critics
really ripped it a new one I mean it
seemed like nobody liked this movie at
all where the criticisms right yeah but
I don't know I think there's some good
stuff in it kinda sorta alright let's
look at the story Michael J Fox is Milo
a janitor at a museum but it turns out
he has a journal that could possibly
lead to the lost civilization of
Atlantis which of course nobody believes
him on that is except for one man who
used to be a friend of his family it
turns out he believes Milo and has been
spending years and years putting
together a team and equipment to go down
and actually find it of course they come
across trouble obstacles and all sorts
of bad things trying to get in the way
until they finally find the city and the
lost people they come across the Emperor
and his daughter named Keita and they
try to figure out the ways of the
culture and civilization as it turns out
the culture and civilization themselves
had forgotten it that's sort of an
interesting idea okay so it sort of
sounds like 20,000 Leagues meets Indiana
Jones meets well Disney there is a lot
of action there is a lot of adventure
but at the same time yeah you do have to
mix it with Disney don't you and if
you're trying to get more of an adult
crowd that's probably not the best thing
to do like listen to this line and tell
me if you think this is more Indiana
Jones or Disney we're gonna rescue the
we're gonna save Atlantis we're gonna
die trying
yeah I'd say Disney - on top of that
guess who the villain is that's right
some asshole who just wants money oh for
God's sake you're looking for a lost
civilization you're gonna be rich either
way but no they want to destroy the
people and just take the artifact so
it's worth even more money Oh gimme a
break I am so sick of these guys but
what does work about the movie well the
culture is pretty cool the people are
pretty cool the sort of magical elements
are pretty cool and on top of that I
really like the side characters they're
all very unique very funny they all
stand out and they have some really good
lines we've done a lot of things we're
not proud of robbing graves and
plundering the tombs of double parking
but nobody got hurt
well maybe somebody got hurt but nobody
we knew I'd be lying if I said the
problems I listed before didn't get in
the way and yeah on the whole is it a
good movie probably not but I think this
is sort of for me what will our Rouge is
for a lot of other people about guilty
pleasure the stuff that's good I think
is really good and really holds up
it's a cornea times oh yeah is it really
stupid you have no idea
but look at this scene
in my opinion there's more here to make
it just a style over substance I mean
the culture is pretty interesting the
people are pretty interesting the
designs are pretty interesting like I
said I do like a lot of these characters
in fact it's one of the few times you
have a Disney couple that doesn't get
married they don't even kiss they just
give a hug dude that's rare but the
problems are major ones and they can be
very very distracting and can ruin the
film for a lot of people it didn't for
me okay keep close but the stuff that's
good I really enjoyed I'm sure it has
its fans I'm sure it has its haters you
can just put me in the fan category I
really liked it despite its annoyances
it's not perfect but I had a lot of fun
watching it